dominic leone on the mound for the
giants three and three with a 1.41 era
of course not a normal starter so now
here is machado another guy who has been
better against right-handed pitching
than he has against lefties so far this
year
tati's not running the pitch a check
swing and he went around with it strikes
3
that was a low cutter dug out of the
dirt by buster posey
and machado tried to check his swing and
couldn't do it and now here comes gabe
kepler and the giants have the
left-hander harleen garcia throwing in
the pan and he's already made the call
for him bases loaded for adam frazier
lined a fair ball down the left-field
line this could clear the bases in from
third is profar tatis behind him
stopping at third is fam it's a double
for frazier and the padres take a
two-nothing lead
here's austin nola
nola oh for four yesterday now here's a
ground ball deep into the hole it's
short crawford fighter was right has it
spins around the long throw to first in
time to get nola
wow
what a play by crawford to save a run at
least
joe musgrove been the padres stopper
all season long 10-9
with a 2.93 era here's the giant home
run leader brandon belt
2-2
swinging a miss and he strikes out belt
first strikeout of the night for joe
mostrow
and manny machado a strikeout victim in
the first inning went swinging
on the ground and a fair ball down the
right field line from second base
grisham will score
satis coming around he's going to try
and score and he will
ball is trapped underneath so they may
send fernando back so fernando's got to
go back to third base
grisham will score its three-nothing
padres and then he gets credit for a
double and an rbi gonna bring up eric
hosmer
popped out to the shortstop first time
up goal for one
line to right field a base hit that'll
score tatis from third machado is going
to try and score the throw will be late
and the padres tack on two more eric
hosmer driving in a pair
so here is evan longoria
now he swings and drives it into right
field twisting toward the line racing
into his left is kofar makes a dive and
can't get it it goes by him in toward
the foul paul in the corner coming
around third is crawford he will score
it's a double for longoria
and the giants have their first run
duggar was not originally in the
starting lineup for san francisco
tonight mikey stremski was to hit eighth
and play center but he was hit by a
pitch on the elbow last night he thought
maybe funny bone just based on his
reaction but that elbow has continued to
bother him and so he's unable to go
tonight here's the 1-2 to duggar and
that is on the outside half strike three
call
giants get a run
when profar cannot make the catch in
right field but that is all longoria's
rbi double put san francisco on the
board but the padres will take a 5-1
lead in the third inning
and with two outs the padres have
two now in scoring position second and
third for jerks and profar
still wanted to he pitches a curveball
roll to first fair ball belt's going to
scoop it up behind the bag he'll race to
the bag and get there ahead of profar
for round number three so he threw three
straight curveballs there and that
helped get him through
the inning back-to-back hits by the
padres but they do not score
it's the middle of the third tonight in
san francisco padres five giants one so
tyro estrada hitting for castro gives
the giants a nice solid inning after
giving up back to back hits he did well
high and deep to left estrada
out of here
how you doing kid
hey pitch it home runs don't come around
very often but he's got one
he continues to impress that's his
seventh home run
of the year for the giants
two down and here's tommy pham
he swings it's a fly ball right field
weighed over wade will make the catch on
the edge of the warning track near the
corner out number three nice job jay
jackson there working around that
lead-off double and it'll bring up evan
longoria double to right field in the
second inning to drive in the first
giants run
moscow looking towards the plate comes
home and this fastball hit in the air
should be routine into shallow left
tommy pham coming in now backpedaling
stumbling a little bit and he reaches
down to make the catch about chest high
to end the inning
i don't know why that one got awkward
but it did no harm no foul no runs no
hits and a man left at second base into
the fifth inning in san francisco padres
lead 5-2
now musgrove will come up
here comes
slider grounded sharply to third
longoria's got it here's the throw to
first
inning over
belta has done very real damage this
season third time through against a
starting pitcher obviously you don't get
a ton of opportunities these days
but he gets one here against moscow
runner on first two outs padres by three
in the fifth two and two to belt pitch
coming and a swing and a miss got him
with a slider that broke down in the
dirt and musgrove's third strikeout of
the night is a big one it ends the fifth
inning
no runs no hits a one-out walk and
flores left at first base after five in
san francisco padres have a 5-2 lead
tatis has had in height three for three
with a double
on the ground up the middle and crawford
with a nice play but it'll be late and
another hit for fernando that's four in
the game
he's got four hits in the game
two of them have been infield hits
bases loaded two down frazier three for
three two and two pitch
ground ball past the mound crawford
behind second has it here's the off
balance throttle first in time right to
belt and the inning is over on nobody on
lamont wade junior left-handed batter
two and two to wade musgrove's [ __ ]
swung on and missed elevated fastball
mighty got a piece of it but tipped it
into the catcher's mitt strike three out
two and the fourth k of the night for
musgrove two away here in the sixth
so two down nobody on here is chris
bryant and the pitch he swings he hits a
high drive into deep left center
still going all the way back to the wall
are yours better
chris bryant to the left of the 399
marker
which can be a graveyard for home run
hitters in this ballpark
and he cleared the wall
with plenty to spare and it's to three
padres
bryant's 25th home run of the season
five three padres tying run coming to
the plate with two outs
it is the very dangerous evan longoria
the much less dangerous stephen duggar
is on deck there's the 01 pitch longoria
hard hit ground ball right to fernando
tatis has it through the first in time
and the side is retired the giants get
one on the bryant homer but muskrobe
threw six innings again and we'll go to
the seventh inning in san francisco
padres leading five to three two outs in
the seventh and here's jerks and profile
driven to the deep left field that ball
is back and it is gone
a two-run home run for jerks and profar
and the padres gets some breathing room
on top seven to three
jerks and profile connects on his fourth
of the year padres needed that
stamen will pitch to duggar
duggar hits one high and deep down the
right field line and
out of here
his eighth of the year
up onto the arcade steven duggar
not all the way down into the bay
but a towering fly ball that made it out
by plenty
duggars home run makes it a 7-4 ball
game giants aren't done yet
so bell will hit with
the belt over shift on
down the right field line
it is out of here
and they're closer again it's 7-5
another time that they have as a team
hit four home runs in the game belt's
25th home run of the year
now remember duggar homer last inning
against stamen
three and two to duggar pagan a couple
of looks back now the pitch and a
fastball swung on and missed strike
three got him to chase up at 96 and
emilio pagan works the houdini act
walking wade and bryant to start the
inning but coming back to get crawford
and longoria and duggar
second and third with nobody out trent
grisham coming up here the padres are
four for 16 with runners in scoring
position in this game
grisham lifts a five ball to center
field duggar will make the catch here
comes frazier from third it comes to
throw and it'll be over him but backed
up and the padres pick up a run
sack fly makes it 8-5
there is will myers to pinch it
on the ground and by the dive of
longoria third coming in from third is
nola
and the padres take a 9-5 lead
now buster posey who is all for four
buster has grounded into a double play
flight out to right
swing the line drive base hit the center
field
belt will come around third and score
and it's nine to six
san diego montlick junior now
to short and fernando
his throw is good and this ball game is
over